Matt Reeves' "The Batman" is everywhere right
now. The first Batman solo movie in 10 years
made more than $164 million at the American box
office just six days into its theatrical run,
and according to Box Office Mojo, it's already
the second-highest-grossing film of 2022.
In "The Batman," Robert Pattinson's Batman has
been patrolling Gotham City's streets at night
for nearly two years with little to show for
it. His fledgling partnership with police
lieutenant James Gordon leaves the two at odds
with the rest of the city's power structure,
and it all comes to head when the Riddler
starts killing Gotham politicians.
Paul Dano's depiction of the Riddler was the
first time the character appears in big-screen
live-action Batman content since Jim Carrey
played the role in 1995's "Batman Forever."
It's a distinctly different approach;
Dano's character appears much more
like a villain in a serial killer movie
than Carrey's loud, bombastic trickster.
"The Batman" also includes villains
The Penguin and Carmine Falcone,
but perhaps the most intriguing villain is one
who makes only an uncredited cameo appearance
at the end of the film. Spoilers ahead!
Barry Keoghan of "Eternals" and "The Killing of
a Sacred Deer" fame is only credited as "Unseen
Arkham Prisoner" in "The Batman," but when he
appears imprisoned alongside the Riddler at
the end of the movie, nobody could mistake
him for Batman's arch-nemesis, the Joker.
Reeves attempts to set up a litany of Batman
villains for his burgeoning cinematic universe.
In fact, a deleted scene reportedly shows Batman
visiting Keoghan in prison to get a profile on
the Riddler, which has fans wondering what the
actor would be like as the clown prince of crime.
While Reeves has said these villains
are in their infancy in "The Batman,"
it seems pretty clear Keoghan's
character will take on the Joker title
in whatever future sequel awaits
Robert Pattinson's Batman.
In the meantime, fans like
Instagram user arifinity_
are offering up sample art of what Keoghan's Joker
could look like with green hair, clown makeup,
and an exaggerated red smile. Behind
Keoghan's Joker is graffiti similar to what
is seen in "The Batman," but Joker-themed.
Keoghan's prison jumpsuit sports the name
"Joe," although it's unclear what
Reeves' Joker's real name is, as of yet.
Reeves told IGN that his conception of Keoghan's
pre-Joker stage involves the character having a
condition that makes it impossible for him to stop
smiling, making his Joker title a reflection of
having lived life as a "cruel joke." However,
the director stressed that Keoghan's inclusion
is not necessarily meant to tease the Joker as
a villain for his next movie. Reeves told IGN,
"I don't know that the Joker would be
in the next movie, but I can tell you
that here's what you're seeing, is an
early days version of this character,
and trouble, as always, is brewing in Gotham."
For the most part, fans are liking the
potential they see in a new kind of Joker.
Instagram user arifinity_ said they
enjoyed "The Batman" in the Instagram
post containing their interpretation
of how Keoghan's Joker could look,
complimenting the film's portrayal of Batman
as a detective, and the effects, posting,
"The visuals were stunning and most of it looked
practical, which I appreciate. Cast chemistry was
great, Paul Dano was probably my favorite out of
the cast. That one scene (iykyk) was exceptional."
Reactions to the user's Joker fan art, which
positions the right half of Pattinson's Batman
opposite the left half of Keoghan as the
Joker, emphasizing the yin-yang nature of
their relationship, appear positive. Plenty
of users left fire emojis in the comments
of the post, and the word "epic"
was tossed around. One user wrote,
"Love this. I wasn't so sure of Barry
playing the Joker but when I saw it...
HIS LAUGH STOLE THE SHOW."
Audiences don't see much of
Keoghan at all in his one scene,
but once his character establishes a
budding friendship with Dano's Riddler,
that unmistakable laugh signals plenty of
trouble ahead for Pattinson's Bruce Wayne.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.